the great wall is directed by email'
zhang one of the most famous chinese
directors working today and stars Matt
Damon and is the very fictional
fantastical story of the Great Wall of
China
and a mythical battle that apparently
went down at one point in time between a
gigantic army and a bunch of iguana
dragon thingies so you know I mean it
sounds awesome yes in fact I was kind of
excited for this movie for one specific
reason this director also held Hiro and
House of Flying Daggers two gorgeous
films that I thought were totally epic
and I was really excited to see what he
could do with a very high budget this is
the most expensive Chinese film ever
made entirely in China and it's a
co-production between a lot of Chinese
production companies and American
production companies and obviously we
have Matt Damon here to sell it to
American audiences and so there was some
controversy because you know he's not
Chinese and there's a lot of Chinese
people it's movie and people were
worried about it being whitewashed or
that it was a white Savior movie we'll
talk about that towards the end of this
video but as a film let's discuss that
first to be honest for about the first
half of this movie I was actually kind
of enjoying it I was having a lot of fun
laughing and enjoying myself but
probably not in the ways the filmmakers
were hoping I would because I found the
film aggressively cheesy and I found
Matt Damon's accent to be incredibly
shaky and very off and on and he seems
very miscast in this movie he doesn't
really fit into this film and it has
nothing to do with the color of his skin
I just feel like the focus of this movie
was very mismatched some of the battle
sequences are huge and grand and they
remind me a lot of the helms deep
sequence in the two towers and then
there are some smaller character moments
and then there's some fun light-hearted
very american moment and then there's
very chinese moments in this film in
which it feels very much so like a
foreign film and then there are moments
where they're like no we have to sell to
america so we're going to have all this
humour and all these little big
superhero moments that don't really make
sense but that's fine because there are
dragons and iguanas this movies allowed
to not make sense which i can kind of
forgive it for that but after that first
half the film is forced to no longer
rely on big over-the-top special-effects
sequence
is that in their defense they're
actually quite a bit of fun and the film
has to show some characters and actually
build some of that character and that's
where the film falters this film has
terrible characters Matt Damon is a
boring bland character there's barely a
single thing interesting about him him
and his partner are in China looking for
black powder we know that as gunpowder
they're eventually captured by this
Chinese army and there's really not much
to him even some of the Chinese generals
in the film and other people involved
with this army where they could have
some depth they just kind of stand
around and yell a lot and make battle
cries and say things that are heroic and
there's just nothing to these characters
so whenever the film isn't involved with
an amazing action sequence it just kind
of goes those action sequences are quite
a bit of fun and there's a lot of them
the CG is most definitely CG I mean
there's there's no way around it and
looks like a bunch of computer-generated
imagery we know it because you know
these things don't exist and this is a
fantasy epic but they just don't look
convincing so we have some fun action
sequences with some beautiful use of
color and a very forgettable throwaway
movie whenever it tries to be dramatic
let's talk about the controversy behind
this movie because yes I am going to go
there I don't feel this movie is being
whitewashed just because Matt Damon is
on the poster he is one actor in this
film and it's a fantasy epic and it's
fictional it's not about something has
actually happened it's not about the
building of the Great Wall of China he
arrives in this film early on and is
taken prisoner by the Chinese and for
the majority of the movie he's either in
shackles behind bars or simply a pawn in
the army he's never the king or the
queen he's barely even a rook if you
want to compare this to a chessboard
he's basically just a really fantastic
Archer who helps out with the army is it
a white Saviour movie is it about a guy
who's white who comes into a culture and
teaches them how to be heroes no I mean
they capture him early on he's very
dirty and filthy and hairy they look at
him and they're like dude clean yourself
up have some respect and he's like yeah
you're right so he shaves and he cleans
himself up and he shows them he's an
amazing Archer but as
being a savior the only person he
actually actively saved in this movie is
one very young inexperienced soldier who
is you know understandably very
frightened because he hasn't really seen
that much of war whereas Damon's
character has and that's really it for
the rest of the movie he is most
certainly a team player if anything he
learns from the Chinese people around
him how to be a more respectable person
how to show honor so I think a lot of
these complaints are very unwarranted
and even the filmmaker himself has been
very outspoken about these complaints as
being offended by them he has said from
the very beginning that this role was
supposed to be for a European character
and not a Chinese man and they always
wanted to get somebody like Damon in
there and obviously they're trying to
market it and you know get more people
to come to the theater but the other
thing that's important is to recognize
that with the amount of money that's
been put into this movie by the the
Chinese production company that has
helped made it being the most expensive
Chinese production ever to be filmed in
China they are heavily relying on this
film success in other places besides
China to continue to expand the Chinese
film market internationally and they're
really looking for this film to be
successful so they can do that so the
people who are detracting this movie
who've never actually seen it who want
more progressive films made by people
outside of America I think aren't
realizing that the success of this movie
is kind of important for that to happen
so it's kind of like you're nearing the
battle against yourself unfortunately I
wish I could sit here and say this is a
good movie it's not for a long majority
of the runtime I found it to be an
enjoyable bad movie and I think you can
actually watch it and shove popcorn in
your face and laugh beyond that though
it's very disappointing and I'm going to
give the great wall a see so guys I am
finally starting to feel a little bit
better I can talk for a long time
without having to cough up a lot of
mucus and phlegm and there you go and
join that image guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my knives
[Applause]
[Music]
you